[Musik]
wir liegen heute in landkarten formaler
verantworten verlauf in zweieinhalb
stunden aus alle maschinen wohnkomfort
wird die strahlung überprüft mit diesem
fall wird man dankbar spot drehen wir
haben hier einmal die beiden himmel
vorne für die beiden bugstrahlruder und
für die beiden extra bruder zum ablegen
würden wir dann den buch strahl goder
auf zwei längen den hexal oder auf 4
bei der hex straße etwas schwächer ist
als ein bugstrahlruder würden dann das
heck etwas mehr öffnen das heißt wir
wollen buch weile geöffnet lassen den
hack strahler auf 647 stellen das heißt
dass das heck etwas mehr öffnet und dann
würden wir das schiff 20 30 meter
parallel bewegen und dann wenn wir vorne
frei sind wir dem buch strahle auf null
setzen bei einer achter aus bewegung
dabei und wenn man dann wenn der bub
freies ungefähr bei 30 bis 40 meter das
schiff achte auslaufen lassen und würden
wir dann wenn das schiff trägt um 4 zeit
den strahler nach backbord legen das
heißt dass man bei einer achter aus
bewegung und vom papier frei drehen wenn
man dann ein auslauf richtung sind dann
würde beide hebel auf pitch 30 voraus
legen und dann die bug und heck
steuerruder stoppen und dann ruder mit
chips und dann den kurs je nach auslauf
richtung natürlich dann anpassen
[Musik]